el presidente aseguró a los
estadounidenses desde la casa blanca que
los tres objetos aéreos derivados por
militares durante el fin de semana
pasado no parecen tener conexión con
ningún programa de vigilancia extranjero
A diferencia de El Globo chino que fue
derivado el cuatro de febrero sobre las
costas del Atlántico nada en este
momento sugiere que estuvieran
relacionados con el programa de globos
espías de China dijo biden resaltando
que es probable que estos tres objetos
fueran simplemente globos vinculados a
empresas privadas sin embargo el
presidente le encargó a su asesor
nacional de seguridad Jake Sullivan que
lidere un grupo interinstitucional para
crear parámetros sobre cómo responder a
este tipo de incidentes cabe mencionar
también que altos funcionarios
estadounidenses aseguraron esta semana
que el primer globo encontrado este
globo chino hacía parte de una programa
de vigilancia de ese país más amplio que
al menos pues tenía tres de esos globos
sobrevolando Estados Unidos en el pasado
durante administración de Donald Trump
dijo también que está en comunicación
con funcionarios del gobierno de China y
reiteró que Estados Unidos no Busca un
conflicto sino competencia en este
sentido reiteró que está no está
buscando una guerra fría pero que
tampoco se disculpará o se disculpa por
haber derivado el globo republicanos por
su parte critican al presidente por
haberse demorado en derivarlo y
supuestamente permitir que este Globo
accediera A información confidencial
estadounidense